it's great to welcome back to the
program today once again Peter phrase
who's an editor at Jacobins magazine
also author of the book for futures from
verso press Peter great to have you back
on yeah thanks for having me back so
let's sort of continue the conversation
you and I started having a while ago
which is number one the changing
relationship between humans and work in
the sort of forty hour a week context
connected to healthcare earning a wage
in the way that is common for most
Americans also the ideas of universal
basic income negative income taxes have
been floated as maybe a way to at least
partially deal with this changing
relationship between humans and work and
automation etc so that's a lot of stuff
I just threw at you but I guess to sort
of open it up in the last year since we
last spoke what direction do you think
the public discussion has gone in is it
a more realistic one that's actually
talking about some of this stuff
well it's talking about some of this
stuff which is a change that we've seen
over the course of certainly you know
the period of time that I've been
studying and writing about these issues
you know we're talking about this on the
level of the effects of say automation
or technology in the workplace this
isn't new it's something that's
recurrent throughout the history of
capitalism for hundreds of years people
have been worried about machines taking
their jobs but this particular iteration
of it has become more and more prominent
in the last five or ten years and it's
come along with increasing attention to
things like the universal basic income
as a way of addressing things like
technological displacement and
automation in ways that don't
necessarily fall into well we have to
create more 40 out of 50 or 60 hour week
jobs for people and it's certainly been
a shift that I've seen in the time that
I've been interested in ideas like the
basic income say for the past 15 years
or so it went from being a very fringe
idea that you
really only find among a handful of
academics or a handful of Fringe
activists mostly on the left although
not entirely - something that now gets
kind of tossed around by CEOs and
political candidates and so on even
something like basic income isn't
necessarily close to being a policy
reality it's certainly something that's
taken seriously as an idea in a way that
it wasn't until fairly recently and one
of the people that's doing that sort of
prominently thanks to some some notable
media appearances over the last three
and six months is 2020 Democratic
presidential candidate Andrew yang and I
I've had some disagreements with him
about the specifics of how he would
implement his what he calls the freedom
dividend $1,000 a month in that I've
pointed out that if you get a thousand
dollars of value from a variety of
welfare programs replacing that with
with a thousand dollars in cash is not
super useful in terms of raising your
standard of living now Andrew argues
that by distinct missing and not means
testing those thousand dollars the
recipient will be better off for example
but that seems sort of marginal to me so
I'm curious if you have any particular
thoughts about his plan and about
implementations that might be better in
your mind
sure so as these things go from what I
understand at least of the contours of
his plan as he's talked about it it's
sort of not the best and not the worst
from my point of view of a basic income
plan now as you sort of alluded to one
of the big questions that arise when
you're evaluating basic income as a
policy idea and as a kind of point of
political principle is what does it both
what does it replace and how much is it
basically the what does it replace
question is very important because as
you said all of these ideas generally I
conceptualize the basic income as
replacing some sort of transfers that
already exist that's part of how it's
funded that can mean just things like
food stamps for example that are
consumed times called near cash benefits
it can include things like means-tested
welfare payments you know gang I think
also talks about disability payments
being replaced which then raises
some questions that maybe we can get
into which is a little dicey er I do
think though that when you're talking
about replacing cash transfers that are
means-tested in various ways there is a
real benefit in that question of de
stigmatizing or to put it another way
it's a question of making people less
reliant upon or subject to the
paternalistic dictates of a welfare
state bureaucracy that makes you jump
through certain hoops whether that's
work requirements or drug testing or
just meeting with caseworkers or filling
out forms to the degree that you know
the unconditional or universal part that
you in you in you be I is important it's
important I think for that kind of
reason now when you look at the range of
proposals for basic income you will see
that there's a wide range of ideas about
exactly what it should or shouldn't
replace so this question of what a basic
income should or shouldn't replace is
pretty important and it bears on the
question of whether a basic income is
really a right wing or a left wing idea
which is something that comes up a lot
in these discussions and that's because
it's one thing to say we should give
everyone you know any amount of basic
income say $1,000 even on top of what
already exists in reality almost every
proposal for a basic income in order to
fund it will say we should replace some
of these cash transfers or near cash
transfers food stamps welfare and so on
but if you get into conservatives like
for example Charles Murray the co-author
of the bell curve in a long time
Washington right wing think-tank person
he wrote a book called in our hands a
decade or more ago in which he proposed
a version of basic income but his
version was called as in the subtitle of
his book a plan to replace the welfare
state by which he meant basically
everything not just food stamps not just
welfare payments but Medicare Medicaid
housing benefits everything would have
to be bought in the market and all you
would get was this face of income
voucher and so that version of basic
income is one that a lot of people on
the Left find disturbing and find to be
a sort of right-wing or neoliberal
Trojan horse to voucherize the entire
welfare state and leave a lot of people
worse off which is why sometimes you get
the distinction that's made that I take
from a collective called the
undercommons that published an article
in Boston review of
this they distinguish between what they
call you bi plus and u bi minus u bi
plus is basically taking the system we
have maybe taking away some of these
conditional cash transfers or
means-tested transfers but leaving in
place you fundamental services like a
right to health care and education and
housing and then supplementing that with
an unconditional cash transfer that
people can use for what they want versus
what they call u bi - which is where
you're essentially taking down the whole
edifice of the welfare state and just
replacing it with a check that will
almost certainly not be enough to cover
it people's needs and also won't be
really a gala terian in the sense that
giving people a voucher to buy
healthcare is unfair in the sense that
different people have different needs
for healthcare depending on whether they
have a chronic illness or whether
they're you know a woman who's going
through a pregnancy or what have you and
so that you may just Roden horse you met
Trojan horse is super interesting to me
because one of the benefits of not means
testing is that you do get to eliminate
bureaucratic waste and all sorts of
infrastructure that is not really
necessary to get people money that could
raise their standard of living or does
raise their standard of living but if
all you're doing is replacing a bunch of
these programs with another one and
eliminating a whole bunch of government
jobs and bureaucracy and waste I like
that idea but it's basically a proxy
towards just small government in a sense
which is a very right-wing idea at its
core well I would say it not necessarily
small government the idea that the size
of government is what matters is I think
what is the right wing idea that like
we're debating whether we're for big
government on the left or small
government on the right Aveda it may not
returns yeah I would argue I'm for small
government in the sense that I want to
drastically cut the military budget
right and I'm also for small government
in the sense that I think there is
something to the libertarian critique
which you can also find in you know left
critics like say Michel Foucault to the
extent that the state to the extent that
the state controls people and sort of
patronizes and paternalistically manages
people's lives in order so that people
can access benefits or access what they
need to live that is
and impediment to human freedom that is
not something we should desire and so
insofar as we can do redistribution with
unconditional transfers that don't
require so much bureaucracy and so much
micromanaging of people's lives I think
that that's a left-wing idea
I don't disagree with you yeah because I
I think we're on the same page as far as
that goes
to talk about the other side of the
equation a little bit what is it that
you see as the most sort of pressing
realization that should be part of the
conversation that isn't about what the
relationship of humans to work will
likely have to be modified to be in the
next 5 10 15 20 30 50 years whatever
timeframe you want to sort of sort of
look at what's one of the fundamental
changes that we are going to have to
come to terms with about how work fits
into our lives that's not really being
given the attention it should well I
think no I don't necessarily want to say
well what we're going to have to decide
yeah what we're gonna have to have a
real debate about beyond what we were
having now I think is to what degree do
we see our societies continue to
continue continuing to be societies in
which people's self-worth people's
position in society is defined primarily
though not entirely by their
relationship to wage labour meaning what
they do as a job what they get paid for
and that's not to say that jobs are all
going to disappear I think that's also a
kind of a mistaken way to have the
argument because it's possible there's
ways we can imagine lots of jobs being
created for people there's people who
argue that the private sector as it has
in the past will throw up new industries
and new jobs for replace ones that
disappear
there's the advocates of things like the
job guarantee which people like Bernie
Sanders and others have talked about at
various times in which the government
creates jobs as the employer of last
resort so it's not that it's not
possible to conceive of continuing to
live in the job based system idea as it
were it's more do we want to live in
that society
or do we want to do one think about free
time freeing up our time to do whatever
we want as really a an ultimate goal of
what we want as a society and also
should we think
more about valorising and recognizing
all the things that people do that's not
paid necessarily whether that's the
reproductive labor that's done primarily
by women in the home whether that's
other kinds of voluntary labor that
people do in concert with others or by
themselves you know it's it's that sort
of big question of social meaning and
social structure I think that we're
going to have to come to terms with as
we move further into a future in which
we could be a less job based less wage
labor based society but we aren't
necessarily going it seems like this is
going directly to the core of whether
you believe in markets or not or to
which degree you believe in markets that
are how free in a sense because there is
a huge sort of socio-political
contingent that works under the umbrella
of the market determines what has value
and if something doesn't have
quantifiable value in some kind of
market it doesn't actually have worth
and and doesn't that fundamentally need
to be upended if we are seriously going
to have this discussion and rethink what
exactly what you're talking about I
think we do have to have that discussion
certainly and there's a variety of
reasons why we should be considering the
value of things that are not necessarily
valued on the market such as for example
as I mentioned reproductive labor which
is the labor that produces the workforce
that is the input to the entire rest of
the economy so in that sense it has
value and yet monetary value is not
historically placed on it by the market
for ecologic 'el reasons of course we
have to think about all the ways in
which ecological costs environmental
costs are not priced by the market in a
way that is sustainable but I think when
we're talking about markets I want to
make a clear distinction between the
idea that things are bought and sold
commodities have prices services have
prices that sort of thing because that
kind of thing can exists in many
different forms of social relations many
different kinds of economies the one
market that I am primarily concerned
with and that I think bears on this
question of basic income of the future
of work and jobs is the labor market
right fact that the marketplace is not
just a price
on the things you own or the things you
produce or the things you buy it places
a price on you and that in a society in
which people mostly do not have a way to
support themselves unless they directly
or indirectly can access paying jobs on
the labour market then yes we're
basically saying we're comfortable with
a society in which the value of human
beings is determined by their
marketability and it's that fundamental
feature of the particular capitalist
market in which we exist is that labor
market that I think is most important to
contest we've been speaking with Peter
frays who's an editor jacoba magazine
also author of the book for futures from
verso press Peter really important
conversation I'm glad it's being had
more and I'm glad to be able to continue
talking about it with you as well yeah
in time thanks for having me back